What's up everybody!
I'm Emil from Pongfinity and welcome to another
episode of Challenge Pongfinity!
This is the series where YOU challenge US
with your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
We will go through all of your comments, pick
the most creative ones and make a video out
of them.
If your idea gets picked, we will feature
it in the video and give you a shout out.
So be sure to leave your ideas in the comment-section
below!
First up is a Facebook-comment that comes
from Gregory Sellers.
Break a single stick of spaghetti by smashing
it from 10 meters away
and then have 10 sticks and smash those from
1 meter away.
This will be an interesting one!
Alright, next up is 10 sticks and only from
1 meter away.
Ooh, that was quite a few.
That was...
I think all of them but one.
Pretty good!
Let's try to hit them 1 more time!
Ahh, okay.
Shark Lite wants us to bounce a ping pong
ball over 3 times on the water.
This reminds a bit of throwing rocks on the
water like this.
I have no idea how this will work with a ping
pong ball, but let's find that out!
I'll give it 5 shots.
Okay, this is the first one.
That was 3 or 4 maybe?
That was a good start!
Second one.
Okay, the 3rd one.
Aaah, only 2 or 3.
Then the 4th one.
Then the last one, 5th one.
Let's try to get 5!
Ooh, I think that was 4 maybe?
We will have to check the GoPro camera, the
slow-mo camera to see if there was 4 or 5.
But at least we got 3 that Shark Lite wanted!
So, this is our pumpkin.
Let's try to see if we can do any damage on
it with some ping pong shots.
So as you can see the pumpkin survived, it's
still smiling
Nothing much happened with it, but it was
fun to try out!
Thanks for watching, I had a fun time filming
this video outside here in Finland although
it's only a couple of degrees here right now.
But if you enjoyed the video leave it a thumbs
up and if you are new to the channel subscribe
right here and watch the previous episodes
here.
Until next time!